una manifestación como hace mucho tiempo
no se veía en París es la que tuvo lugar
hoy en contra de ese proyecto de reforma
de la jubilaciones del gobierno de
Emmanuel macroni no solo en París
también en Marsella tu luz burdeos o
nantes justamente esta huelgara vista
como un pulso entre los sindicatos
debilitados después del movimiento de
los chalecos amarillos y el gobierno de
Manuela macron que dijo desde Barcelona
están determinado a aplicar esta reforma
y la puesta de los sindicatos parece que
ha resultado según el cgt el más a la
izquierda hoy marcharon en París 400.000
personas en el año 2019 cuando hubo la
primera gran marcha en contra del otro
proyecto de reforma de la jubilaciones
de Manuel macron fueron según el mismo
sindicato
200.000 las personas hoy en París Vimos
a sindicalistas que tradicionalmente
participan en este tipo de movimientos
pero también a Personas que quizás nunca
habían venido los bomberos por ejemplo
que no trabajar más porque ya su trabajo
es muy duro o una niña que marchaba con
sus padres y que llevaba una pancarta
que decía aquella quería poder tejer
como lo hace su abuela ahora le toca a
los sindicatos decidir si van a
reconducir este movimiento hubo tanta
gente en París que incluso hubo un
recorrido paralelo al cortejo y también
hubo desórdenes aunque no lograron
empañar esta jornada